so contempt is criticism on steroids
this is what John gottman calls sulfuric
acid for love nothing will erode a
relationship quicker than contempt
contempt is when you are looking at your
partner from a superior position so you
are eye rolling you are name calling
um there's a mockery mocking even
physical mockery imitating them
imitating their voice contempt is meant
to just take the legs out from your
partner make them feel pathetic
ridiculous
um and it can be abusive but
um most people have engaged in contempt
at some point in their relationship
lower level would be sort of the eye
rolling but that is the biggest
predictor of a split if you allow
yourself to think yeah that mockery or
contempt just a little bit
it's like this weird slippery slope sure
is and the opposite is true
where I just look at a person think wow
isn't that the most like wonderful
creature I've ever seen in my life like
just think that and you notice the
little details about who they are and so
I just observe them the way you observe
like a weird like peacock at a zoo or
something like that attention is
powerful isn't it yeah and it changes it
you start to notice beautiful things and
then let
uh the things that annoy you yes like
just you're exactly right you're
touching on some really important things
so in relationships we actually know
that wearing rose-colored glasses is
important it's healthy we need it
um and it's a choice you're baking right
so there is a saying that uh getting
married is just choosing one person's
faults over another and the reality is
that we may become infatuated with
somebody else as human beings love is an
emotion attraction is emotion an emotion
and as you go through life even if
you're in a committed relationship you
might see Beauty in another and that
person who is novel might seem
attractive to you but if you can
remember that they too have a set of
problems that you would be marrying it
really helps you to see the beauty in
your partner again and recognize all of
their incredible strengths and all the
ways we meld with the person become our
own family almost become I mean our
lives intertwine and we grow those oak
trees so as you by the way it's a line I
read somewhere that uh when you're
wearing rose-colored glasses all the Red
Flags looks just like Flags
I think it's a good it's a good line uh
so you so you think that humans are
fundamentally all of us are
fundamentally flawed or have flaws
they're unique flaws and that basically
relationships is just the way to um
figure out how the two can fit together
right and we're different so no matter
what we're going to have differences we
are raised differently than our partner
we have different stories different
experiences that shaped our value
systems especially when it comes to the
big ones like parenting love money
um these principles that are based in
our history
we're going to have differences so are
is this a set of differences you can
accept from somebody and work with do
the benefits and their strengths
um do they make it worth it or is it are
they deal breaker differences